I am a actor physician I practice
emergency medicine I work at busty and I
teach high school math there's nowhere
we'd rather be right now than taking
this awful awful test we take the SATs
in high school right see this is already
going bad I studied for probably an
entire year for this exam I didn't study
like a lot of the other folks my father
got this video where it taught
sense-memory if you smell an apple
you'll remember certain phrases and
words and equations so I brought my
apple of the day I am a teacher and I do
value standardized testing but I also
think that the SAT advantage privileged
populations and so students who don't
have the opportunity to take extra
classes won't you as well which isn't
fair all right let's do it
I'm ready can you show this up in your
hand no no I don't want to say it out
loud but that's my general attitude so I
wrote about Hitler this can't be good I
read about rappers so but like what I
wrote was kind of what Kanye would say
so I'm very confident in what I wrote
all right question 17 in section two in
the XY plane which I have no idea what
that is anymore the line L passes
through the origin and it's what is an
origin Harry Potter family symbol or
something like that because our number
six look at the ketchup
this is important sentence three the
harmful effects of smoking on the
vascular system are increasingly
well-documented that's a fact
whoever wrote these paragraphs sounds
like a complete douchebag
yeah I think it's written in the most
convoluted way possible to test your
reading comprehension but in fact it's
just like bad writing this is so bad
all right that's not as bad as I thought
hey I'll take it my math is lower than
everything else which is horribly
embarrassing even though I scored pretty
good so in high school I had a perfect
score in math and it's my worst score
here failed at math for me personally I
don't think it's gonna change anything
at this point
you know not planning on going back to
undergrad I think I've done enough
school at this point it was more a test
of who knew the tricks around the
problems rather than how smart you
actually are I think it's good to have a
standardized test honestly but don't
stress too much about it I mean do well
enough to get into undergrad or whatever
but once you're there just work hard
there so your life is not defined by
anyone's score
this person spell heaven wrong she he
gets an F and critical reading